all right guys we have to get ahead of a
major propaganda story that is uh
breaking today and happening
exactly as predicted i have no special
psychic
insight i just knew it was going to
happen because we understand how donald
trump operates we have received the
estimated third quarter gdp number for
the united states
and annualized gdp growth for q3
was an astounding incredible 33.1
gdp growth wow and if you look at just
that number
at a superficial level turn your brain
off throw logic into the trash and do no
research whatsoever
you might say this country is doing
unbelievably well economically we are
back wow this is unbelievable
and you're going to get hit by some
insane propaganda
from donald trump and his campaign in
the next five days leading up to the
election
which will try to convince you of
exactly that
it is bs and you must be prepared for it
so gdp changes are relative
to the prior status quo
of the gdp remember that in the second
quarter
due to coronavirus usgdp dropped more
than 31 percent
that's a record we have never had as
big a gdp decrease as we had in the
second quarter of this year
so when we say gdp is up 33
in the third quarter it is up relative
to the record decline that we had in the
second quarter
before this year the biggest ever
decrease to the gdp was in 1921's
second quarter of 28.6 the biggest
increase was actually 40
in 1879 q4 the country was very
different then it's not even really
relevant to compare that but okay
and just as i predicted three months ago
when the second quarter numbers came out
donald trump tweeted this morning
exactly what i told you he would i've
been preparing you for this for three
months
donald trump tweeting quote gdp number
just announced
biggest and best in the history of our
country
and not even close next year will be
fantastic
however sleepy joe biden and his
proposed
record-setting tax increase would kill
it all
so glad this great gdp number came out
before november 3rd yeah
he is glad so let's understand what's
going on here be
armed with the numbers if you work for
me imagine i hire you to be my
you know hype man or woman
or whatever and i pay you a salary of 50
000
a year okay if after the first year
i give you a thirty one percent cut that
lowers your salary
salary from fifty thousand dollars a
year to thirty four thousand five
hundred
and then the next year i say hey i'm
gonna give you a thirty three percent
raise this is a huge record raise i've
never given anybody a 33
raise you're going to get it and after
the 31
cut and the 33 raise you are
actually still well below
your original salary of 50 000
now this is exactly what they're doing
here there are people who do not
understand math who think well we went
down
31 and up 33 we're back
we're better than ever we're recovered
but of course that's not the case
remember that if something goes down 50
percent
it then needs to go up a hundred percent
to get back to where we were i mean just
let's apply this to make it easy to the
number 100 which we're putting up on the
screen
if you start with a 100 and lose 31
percent you're down to 69
that's easy if you then get 33 percent
back from that 69 you're only
up to about 91 so you are
still about eight and a half percent
below where you started so
now six months after
the end of the first quarter we had the
second quarter
and the third quarter and we are still
down 8.23 percent from where we started
on april 1st this is a stunning
economic contraction and case in point
the gdp after this explosive
record-setting growth that donald trump
is bragging about
our gdp is now back up to where it was
two and a half years ago in the first
quarter of 2018
you were going to get hit very very hard
with propaganda and talking points but
now you
understand the math of it one of the
ways that the right
distorts reality is to ignore the recent
past and
if you look just at q3 wow
33 up but that's only if you ignore
the second quarter i'm not expecting the
media to highlight this and to make it
clear
and you need to come armed with the
information yourself
because this is trump's last stand folks
um 80 million people have already voted
we have five days until the election
this is i told you this would be the
last ditch effort to say
we did it don't fall for it don't let
other people fall for it friends don't
let friends fall
for obviously bad math that's gdp let's
now talk about coronavirus and the stock
market
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you 15 off everything
in the store
if you're a guy looking for the perfect
way to refresh your style
one of the best investments you can make
is in a high quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about two
hundred dollars but it'll look like you
spent a lot more
all of their watches are made in small
batches from top quality materials
and they just look great i went on their
site and picked out
a watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got is in mesh
matte black and i love it it's simple
sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it
you'll get fifteen percent off
everything in their store
when you go to davidpakman.com
i've put the link right underneath this
video